one of the things that I think is really
important
is for a society to kind of feel right
not just get the policies right but like
when you walk around that you should see
you should see beautiful things you
should see good architecture right you
should see buildings that are an
expression of humanity and actually
Tucker and Russell got into that as well
and I think it is I actually do believe
it is connected to what has been so
broken about the human spirit that has
led us to what we're dealing with right
now
architecture changed completely and it
went from designs that complemented the
landscape around them to a kind of
architecture that clearly hates people
that is designed to oppress the human
spirit and make people feel without
value worthless I think if you brought
someone from the streets of Tokyo to the
Cotswolds and so what do you think of
that building you'd say that's beautiful
because beauty is inherent every person
recognizes Beauty a Shinto temple in
Kyoto I recognize it immediately is
beautiful because it is it's consistent
with the symmetry of nature Municipal
and state buildings were once plainly an
expression of a contract between the
people and the government of uh Faith
relationship I just thought that I
walked up with my wife in the rain on a
village hall and I thought whoever built
that cared about the people it was built
by the people who lived there for the
people who live there and they loved the
people live there because they were
related to them or knew them it was
built by peasants without machines yeah
okay you know it's true right what
Tucker just said there like you look at
something beautiful and you know it's
true and then it and then and you know
it's beautiful right and then someone
else from a completely other culture
could walk up and see something
beautiful and know it's beautiful it's
innate to Being Human so we we need to
build beautiful things I do the best I
can within my house in terms of artwork
and plants and everything that we have
here to make it beautiful so that when I
walk around and my team is here during
the day they you feel good you see good
things around you and you feel good and
then hopefully it adds a little
something to your spirit and then you
can do better work you can be happier
and more fulfilled throughout the day
and and sometimes uh guys we have to we
have to basically
stop and smell the roses and see those
things and acknowledge it because we
went from neoclassical cities like DC to
the postmodern looking McDonald's on
every corner it does not have to be this
way DC once built beautiful buildings
and then it turned into these giant
monstrosities
[Music]
thank you